hello everyone and welcome back to the
chess 24 legends of chess tournament
2020. now today we are starting with the
video a little bit earlier
uh as magnus has his uh fantasy football
thing later on and he asked
if they could play their match uh a
little bit sooner so uh the two of them
have already finished before the other
players have even started
uh i don't know much about fantasy
football league but i i do know magnus
is currently uh the
i believe fourth in the entire world out
of some seven and something million
players
and he has uh he has a chance to to win
the whole thing so it is a
a very big deal as i understand it uh so
that's why ding agreed to face him
earlier so here uh we have
a very nice game it's game two of their
match game one ended in a draw
and even though it was extremely
interesting
uh ding played a very interesting
opening it was a new game
already out of move four and uh well in
the end it ended in a draw but this one
really a beautiful game i do hope you
enjoy it and that it
will at least slightly improves your
sunday
sorry i'm uh i'm a bit a bit out of
breath i was uh
doing some light exercises and i thought
i thought it'd be a good idea to do a
video right after that but apparently
it's not so let me just
like take 10 seconds
yeah really really weird stuff uh okay
so getting back to the game
magnus opens with d4 uh we have knight
to f6
uh c4 e6 we have knight to f3 and d5
so the queen's gambit declined is on the
board uh sorry about
that uh and knight the c3 now uh we have
c6 uh and here we have the semi slav
defense and the bishop to g5 we go into
h6
uh and the bishop of the bishop to h for
the anti-moscow gambit
uh we have d captures on c4 and now
grabbing the center with e4
so this has all been played before uh
plenty of times and it's uh well it's a
really a bit of a a bit of a long
theoretical struggle so here
uh ding replies with the g5 with bishop
to g3
uh and now b5 uh with bishop to e2
all been played before and bishop to b7
and here uh the most often played move
is actually h4 but this is one of the
well one of the rare cases where magnus
does not go e uh
does not go with something like h4 uh in
the style of lila
as we say nowadays but rather castles uh
and now
knight b to d7 and now the the most
common move here is knight to e5
uh which does make sense um however here
we have knight the d2
and uh still not a new move it has been
played once before
uh in that game that was played h5 was
the move it was uh played in 2010 in
sarajevo
uh between alexander fear and vassif uh
durbaily
where black was able to win the game
with h5 but here we have knight to b6
sorry
we have queen to b6 by ding and it is
already as of movie 11 that we have a
completely new game
uh so how will how will magnus deal with
this uh obviously the d4 pawn is under
attack so magnus defends it
indirectly with a tactic he plays a4
and now what do you do here is black if
you go after the pawn i just ate capture
some b5
and this is sufficient for for white to
claim huge advantage actually
uh because if you capture then you just
allow knight captures on b5 with all
sorts of
sorts of threats knight to c7 is coming
the queen will be under attack
uh and you don't really have any any
good replies here the c4 pawn is hanging
both the bishop and the knight are
attacking it you have a nice semi-open
file for the rook
so it doesn't really doesn't really pay
to grab the d4 pawn so here we have a6
biting
uh just uh defending that pawn and now
e5
are challenging the knight on f6 uh we
have knight to d5 and now
knight d to e4 now getting this knight
to
a very nice outpost in the future knight
f6 knight the d6 knight c5 might be some
excellent squares
and also the queen now does guard the d4
pawn so here it didn't go
c5 that makes sense you want to get rid
of that pawn
uh it's a double pawn you attack the
center and you'll your light square
bishop also comes alive so here
magnus finds a very nice idea knight
captures on d5
uh we have bishop captures and the
knight back to c3 now attacking the
bishop here
and here ding uh well there are a couple
of moves you could play
but the ding chooses one that is the
absolute sharpest so it didn't go c
characters on b4 which involves a pawn
sacrifice by magnus and it looks very
scary the knight is under attack
d3 is coming so it could be could be
very dangerous but
in fact it's not and magnus calculates
precisely knight captures on d5
e captures on d5 and now bishop to h5
and the threat of e6 is just too great
for
for black to simply just avoid for
example if d3
uh just opening up the the queen's
diagonal maybe the bishop can also
come and help out with uh with the
attack you have a beautiful pass pawn on
d3
however e6 just wins the game on the
spot this is now a threat
this is now a threat and there there is
no good move for example if you capture
with the queen just rookie one
uh and you lose the queen on the other
hand you could play something like
bishop to e7
and it is in fact the absolute best way
for black to play
uh however you still will uh will get uh
attacked here for example e6
queen captures in rookie one white can
sacrifice this pawn and after the queen
moves it's
uh it looks incredibly ugly for black
but
if it works if it works why not
uh because you kind of let's say queen
to g4 or bishop to g4
will prevent black from castling king's
side since the knight here is hanging
castle in side also not all the great
eight captures and b5 just opens the the
rook's uh
file so it would be uh maybe it is
playable but not in rapid game with
little time on the clock
so here instead instead of those uh well
instead of the bad option and the good
option ding chose the third option
which just loses the game ding chooses
c5
knight to c5 but now feel free to pause
the video here and try to find
the winning idea for magnus while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the winning move is actually the first
move you thought of
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's queen capture sunday
for
ding somehow overlooked this for some
reason
uh magnus just grabs a pawn uh the the
other pawn is still being threatened and
of course
knight b3 with the fork doesn't work
because uh well ding's queen is not
defended on b6 so he would just wander a
queen and if something like uh rook to
d8 you still face the moves like e6 and
now
everything is hanging like you can't
capture with the knight because the
queen hangs
if you capture with the queen then the
rook hangs also now there the rook is
under attack
so there is really nothing for for black
to play here uh this
is coming this is just attacked so i
mean it's a
game over for black here so instead ding
chose to block the pawn with the queen
queen to e6 but now
magnus continues in great style we have
bishop to g4
now forces the queen back although the
queen cannot really move
because if queen to c6 then you get e6
once again
and again the rook is under attack
everything is just hanging
for example if rook to h7 you can go
bishop f5 you just continue going after
the rook and if rook g7
now a capture spawn captures rook
captures queen captures and now even e7
is in the position so
completely crazy crazy stuff if bishop
captures then
you can capture the rook uh and other
than that there is really nothing for
example if king captures now you can
just choose either bishop to e5 to win
the rook you can play rookie one just to
check the king
queen captures and c5 is an option uh
just everything falls apart for the ink
so here after bishop to g4 attacking the
queen
ding tried a counter attack with knight
to b3 now with a nice fork
however magnus replies with the only
winning move for white
the bishop is still being attacked here
so you do need to move the queen while
defending the bishop
and this is exactly what magnus does
queen to d1 now defends the bishop and
the ding now
has to move the queen so queen to c6 and
first
b4 executing e6 magnus trades once here
because it comes with tempo
the queen is under attack so queen
captures and now comes
finally e6 again a beautiful exchange
sacrificed by magnus
problem is if you go after the rook then
the bishop pair from hell
becomes just too strong for example if
it just captures an f7 king captures and
queen f3 check
there's no continuing this you are
getting checkmated uh doesn't matter how
you how you play let's say king e8
rookie one check king d8
you're gonna get queen to f6 check and
now all of these squares are covered by
the
bishop pair from hell so the king is
doomed you can go let's say bishop e7
just queen captures is checkmate
so here uh after e6 ding tried just
capturing and now
magnus recaptures bishop captures on e6
but now the line in front of the king
has opened up
and it's going to be very dangerous so
here
what uh what you could try let's say you
try rook to d8
the d5 pawn is also under attack here so
you might also want to defend that but
if that
then it's just a very quick check made
queen h5 checking e7 and queen to f7
checkmate
so a lot of a lot of poison in the
position so after this uh bishop
captures an e6 move we have rook to a7
uh being trying to get the rook to help
out with the defense of the seventh
frank and
the king but now uh bishop captures on
d5 by magnus
and here uh ding really doesn't have a
good move the king is still in the
center of the board rookie one check is
coming the queen is coming into the game
maybe with queen to
h5 maybe with queen to f3 it's uh just
uh
impossible to find a decent move so here
dangerous played
a knight captures rook on a1 hoping that
okay at least now i'm up a full rook and
maybe if
magnus messes up you know the the
material might come in handy however
magnus just played queen to f3 and it
was in this position on move 26 that
dingler and resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here
the threat is terrible uh bishop the c6
check will win the queen
and there's not much you can do about
this uh
you could try moving the queen or
something as i mean you should
uh but then just rookie one check and
you're still getting
just destroyed for example king d8
you're gonna get queen to f6 with
check uh everything is hanging queen
king to see it let's
rookie check there are no more squares
for the king king the d7 is the only
move the bishop covers c7
and after this let's say rook v8 and
this is checkmate
so uh nothing works out for ding here
after queen to f3 he resigned uh or
maybe he didn't resign maybe he ran out
of time let me just
quickly check this uh sorry about that
uh let me just quickly check although i
don't think he ran out no no he still
had two minutes on the clock magnus said
six minutes so
uh everything is good here being
resigned and an excellent victory for
magnus
and since the match is already over i
will now mention the result of the match
uh game
three and game four ended in a draw so
it's magnus who wins the match
before uh even going to armageddon so he
gets the full three points
and we'll see if he will also be able to
win the
fan fantasy football league later on uh
in the fourth game magnus had a winning
position uh however
he agreed to a draw as a draw was all he
needed to
claim a win uh in this match so of
course it would be silly to
pursue a win as you don't really gain
anything by it
uh so yeah uh that's uh the game i do
hope you enjoyed it uh sorry about
those 10 seconds i wasted of your time
in the moment i i never thought it would
be you know a big big deal uh you know
doing some light exercise and then doing
a video but obviously it is
uh i would also like to thank uh mike
gerth uh kimmel and slansti
uh nick nakaniki uh leo turkey and
loomis
and milk milkson for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage
of the magnus uh well uh the chest 24
legends of chess
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so uh thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day
and end the sunday